hey Luke and Tom here with the outdoor
boys YouTube channel and we are going to
tell you a little about kayak safety
gear up if you go kayaking you're doing
a real danger is falling out okay if you
fall out of your kayak or canoe by
yourself then the question becomes how
do you get back in now if you're close
to shore you can swim your kayak back to
shore and get in that way but if you're
in deep water and you need to get back
in you're by yourself it can be pretty
tricky now if you're a little guy like
this dude it's pretty simple because you
don't kick the kayak over it's trying to
get it out but if you weigh 250 pounds
like me it's like watching an elephant
seal try to get on the beach so I'm
going to show you a trick now a lot of
people when they fall out they'll try to
get back in by climbing it over the side
okay and if you're really careful you
might be able to do it but up here but
if you weigh 250 pounds and you're in a
smoke canoe or kayak it's really hard
especially in canoes because canoes
higher out of the water okay kayaks are
a lot more forgiving in this situation
especially this is a tandem kayaks so
it's a lot bigger okay
[Music]
hotman in a little boat there is a
better way to get into a kayak or canoe
if you fall out let me show you so this
is how you do it and that until a fat
man gets into a little boat let me show
you that one more time okay come in on
the tip okay shove it down and there you
go you're it now one thing is if you do
this on a canoe there's less surface
area right here it's easier to swap the
boat with the canoe however it takes a
little bit of time to swamp a canoe so
do it quickly
and even if your swamp in it you can get
in quickly you won't bring in that you
won't take on that much water if you
fall out of a kayak on a windy day it
can be very dangerous
an empty kayak will probably when the
wind pushes against it if you fall out
you better start swimming quick for that
kayak or you're going to be on your own
that's why we always wear life vest in
canoes or kayaks because there's lots of
situations that can really get you in
danger even if you're a good swimmer
getting back into a canoe or kayak yet
empty is a lot easier than getting into
one that's walk so let me show you some
tricks about what to do if you swap your
kayak or canoe okay so with that okay
the canoes flipped over
it actually has it really o'clock yes so
what you do is you go underneath it I'm
grabbing the opposite gunnel the on the
opposite side and I'm going to push up
while I pull down okay
now we're pretty well fought okay go
what you do and you start bailing with
whatever you can a time done start
slapping a water outlet and you do this
for a very long time
honestly I already I already got about
another inch of free board from doing
this so let's just keep going fatter you
are the more you need to do this before
you get the bow-wow by the way this is
much much easier in a kayak especially a
big tandem class I wish I could have
shown you on my canoe but someone stole
it so we're doing the kayak today okay
at this point I bailed out all bit about
an inch of water in the bottom and now
they get get up that's gratefully tip
time and that how you get into canoe or
kayak when you swap it although that
process only took about two or three
minutes so this is something you can do
pretty quickly but once again it's much
more forgiving a lot easier in a kayak
than it is a canoe additionally this is
why you don't overload canoes or kayaks
because if you're just getting into an
empty canoe or kayak it's pretty simple
if I had two hundred pounds of gear
strapped in here oh boy
that'd be a problem so the one upside is
if you do have gear in your kayak or
canoe you can shift it around to be like
a counterbalance the same way you would
use a friend to help you get in if
there's two adults in here you want the
lightest guy to go in first and then
once he's in he can you be a
counterbalance to help bring the other
person once you guys are in if you want
you can bail out the remaining water or
paddle to shore and dump out your canoe
kayak did you know some packs are
designed
and fisherman's guy acts like this
tandem old town excursion to fabulous
we're fishing from I can stand up in
space from the thing panel from it never
fallen out that's what I want to thanks
for watching the outdoor boys YouTube
channel we hope you like this video if
you'd like to see more videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to that's right we put out new
videos every week
[Music]